président lui-même a reconnu qu'il y
avait eu ce mensonge d'état
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ses accusations elle pose quand même la
question du traitement des dissidents
par votre mouvement c'est des
accusations politiques qui n'ont rien à
voir avec les allégations portées devant
la justice espagnole
nous n'avons jamais expulsé ni les
organisations des droits de l'homme ni
la presse alors que le maroc les ont
occupés aujourd'hui sont servis est-ce
que désormais il ya un risque de voir
s'installer un conflit militaire sur la
durée les lignes rouges sont déjà
franchi qu'on a guère a commencé après
que le maroc a annexé encore et partie
de notre territoire nous avons accepté
un plan de paix qui consiste à
l'organisation d'un référendum
d'intervention pour laisser les
sahraouis le choix de choisir le futur
de choisir entre l'indépendance et
l'intégration maroc à savoir que ce
n'est pas une partie du territoire
marocain
[Musique]
elle a une le sénat s'est à son tour ce
vendredi d'examiner le projet de loi
d'extension du pass sanitaire en france
au terme de débats intenses les députés
ont voté pour
à l'aube à noter cette volte face de
dernière minute les hôpitaux et les
ehpad sont concernées sauf les urgences
et ils ont aussi voté pour la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants
autre projet de loi qui fait débat
également le séparatisme parlement a
adopté définitivement le texte il s'agit
de lutter contre l'islamisme radical
mais beaucoup considèrent que le
remettre en cause certaines libertés
individuelles les explications dans ce
journal
et puis les jeux olympiques de tokyo
sont officiellement verts ont démis
oblige une atmosphère particulière règne
dans la ville japonaise il y a ceux qui
n'en veulent pas le font savoir dans la
rue et puis les compétitions qui se
dérouleront cette année sans public
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france les sénateurs
étudie à leur tour le projet de loi sur
l'extension du pass sanitaires ils
espèrent plus de souplesse
après l'adoption à l'eau par les députés
de la loi dans l'hémicycle les débats
ont été rudes et décision de dernière
minute il faudra son pass pour se rendre
dans les hôpitaux où on n'est pas de
souffle dans les urgences
l'assemblée qui a voté également pour la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants
reste à savoir comment le sénat va s'y
prendre
les précisions avec notre reporter katia
pique nique au palais du luxembourg
c'est un texte vraiment très controversé
qui a été votée à 5h40 du matin à marche
forcée disaient certains députés
globalement l'obligation de vaccination
pour les soignants les sapeurs-pompiers
le personnel des ehpad ou des maisons de
santé fait globalement consensus mais
l'extension du passani terre non d'où ce
vote en première lecture très partagés
117 voix pour 86 contre l'exécutif à une
course de vitesse pour sa stratégie
contre le variant delta mais
l'opposition a contesté cet examen
expéditifs le parti communiste la france
insoumise et les socialistes ont voté
contre et députés républicains se sont
en majorité abstenus craignant que l'on
met le pays sous cloche et contestant
les incohérences du pass sanitaire le
fait que tous les français qui le
souhaitent donc pas encore pu se faire
vacciner
ce qui fait débat également c'est le
licenciement au bout de deux mois
envisagé pour les salariés des lieux
culturels ou de loisirs accueillant du
public qui n'aurait pas de passes
sanitaires à jour il pourrait être
congédié alors les professionnels de
l'hôtellerie et de la restauration sont
contre cette mesure
ils ne veulent pas payer les indemnités
de licenciements licenciements qui ne
souhaitent pas les syndicats la cfe cgc
fo et la cgt se sont manifestés ce matin
ils ont dénoncé un dérapage un texte
dangereux pour la première fois un motif
de licenciement relevant de la vie
privée
il y aura donc beaucoup de questions à
régler pour les sénateurs aujourd'hui
lors de la procédure accélérée des
débats qui risque d'être moins vifs
selon le sénateur républicain
roger karoutchi le vice président du
sénat mais des débats tout de même pour
rendre le pass and i ter plus cohérent
pour qu'il préserve
avantage des libertés ont l'écoutent y
aura des débats lourd sur quel équilibre
entre les contraintes d'accepter avec le
pass sanitaires et la liberté
comment fait-on parce qu'on a dénoncé un
certain nombre de choses aberrantes soit
des conditions de sanctions financières
excessives qui n'avait pas de sens soit
des aberrations sur le thème on vous
demande un passani terre pour nous
asseoir une terrasse de café alors que
vous êtes en plein air est ce que
vraiment il faut un passani terre à ces
conditions alors qu on ne vous demande
pas de passe à dix terre pour rentrer
dans un grand magasin - centre
commercial de moins de vingt mille
mètres carrés donc il ya des
contradictions on va essayer d'avancer à
des amendements
si le gouvernement est ouvert les choses
se passeront pas trop mal ici et on
pourra avoir avec l'assemblée nationale
et nos réunions de concertation de
commission mixte paritaire qui sera
conclusive
si évidemment le gouvernement est
totalement fermé à toute avancée
ça risque d'être plus compliqué plus
long et de ne pas avoir d'accord les
sénateurs vont donc travailler ce
week-end 260 amendements à examiner en
commission aujourd'hui
ensuite ce sera la discussion générale à
partir de 21h30 dans l'hémicycle et
l'examen des articles reprendra demain à
9h30 et à propos des volte face de la
nuit sur deux amendements écouter ce
qu'en pense notre éditorialiste un
nicolas vidal
hier les députés ont voté contre l'axé
contre le bassin fait d'avoir le passé
car pour accéder aux établissements de
santé et aux ehpad pour les patients non
urgents et les accompagnants et ben non
eh ben non eh ben non ça a été voté et
olivier ferrand cette nuit à 5 heures du
matin avant le café croissants a fait
revoter parce qu'apparemment le vote ne
lui convenait pas surtout gouvernement
est pas qu olivier ferrand donc
finalement ça a été ça a été remis en
place vous imaginez aujourd'hui il
faudra un passani terre pour aller voir
un prof même si vous même vous êtes
touchés par la maladie ou un problème
médical
vous devrez avoir un pass à litière pour
accéder à l'hôpital mais qu'est ce que
c'est ce pays me qu'est ce que c'est
c'est ce débat citoyen avec un vote
il ya des choses absolument incroyable
là tu sais la fin d'une liberté
déplacement c'est la fin du secret
médical
tout ça est absolument incroyable et
sachez que certaines mesures sanitaires
font leur retour comme le port du masque
en extérieur de nouveau en vigueur dans
plusieurs villes notamment celles dont
le taux d'incidence est proche du seuil
d'alert à des mesures nécessaires selon
le chef de service réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris
bruno m'égare ban que l'on écoute
aujourd'hui les contaminations progresse
de façon exponentielle
il y à un risque majeur que dans
quelques jours on puisse assister à une
quatrième vague hospitalière tout doit
être fait pour éviter que les
contaminations s'aggrave davantage et
donc effectivement dans l'état actuel de
la vaccination qui est encore
insuffisante pour prévenir
l'augmentation des hospitalisations
il faut malheureusement mettre en place
un certain nombre de mesures de
restriction c'est une course de vitesse
entre une épidémie qui progresse de
façon exponentielle en termes de
contamination et une vaccination qu'il
faut atteindre la plus large possible
pour protéger contre les formes graves
voire l'étal de la maladie et donc
effectivement plus on met des moyens
pour on va dire accélérer la vaccination
et mieux c'est je crois que le pass
vaccinale le pass sanitaire pardon a eu
un double intérêt tout d'abord bien sûr
de pousser à la vaccination le plus
largement possible mais aussi de
garantir des espaces de vie collectifs
où finalement il n'y a pas de danger et
on va prendre maintenant la direction
des états unis confrontés à la
propagation du variant delta responsable
selon les autorités sanitaires de 83%
des nouvelles infections ont fait le
point tout de suite avec notre
correspondant à washington thomas boni
[Musique]
thomas bonjour bonsoir quelle est la
situation dans le pays et comment on le
gouvernement compte il y faire face et
bien aux etats-unis le variant delta est
responsable d'une hausse du nombre de
cas positifs de 55 % en l'espace d'une
semaine avec un nombre de 37 mille
nouveaux cas par jour en moyenne en ce
moment sur l'ensemble du territoire
américain
et il y a des inquiétudes en particulier
dans les états où la couverture
vaccinale est nettement inférieure à
celle de la moyenne nationale aliens
question maintenant qui anime les débats
ici doit-on imposer de nouveau le masque
en intérieur y compris pour les
personnes non vaccinées les autorités
sanitaires la cie dc avait indiqué le 13
mai dernier que le port du masque
n'était plus nécessaire pour les
américains vacciner à l'intérieur mais
face à cette dégradation des indicateurs
sanitaires la question est de nouveau
sur la table alors il n'y a pas de
décision pour le moment c'est ce qu'ils
ont annoncé hier et la question a donc
été posée à la porte parole de la maison
blanche est ce que le gouvernement
compte d'une façon ou d'une autre et
imposer de nouvelles restrictions et
puis quelle est la position de la maison
blanche sur le port du masque
d'intérieur écoutez sa réponse
et bien c'est actuellement notre message
pour les communautés parmi lesquels il
ya des taux de vaccination plus faibles
et comme nous le savons elles sont
vraiment concentrés seulement dans un
atelier d'état à travers les pme d'où
viennent la plupart des cas comme nous
l'avons constaté avec la propagation du
variant delta ce qu'il y ait plus
transmissible
si l'on n'est pas vacciné il se transmet
plus rapidement d'une personne à l'autre
et de ce line up et qu'aucun de open les
gens devraient porter des masques et
c'est quelque chose que nous continuons
à encourager de la part des leaders les
rigueurs de la société civile c'est les
enseignants et les personnes
la parole jouit de la confiance de leurs
communautés à faire comprendre voilà
étant donné qu'il n'y a pas de
directives claires de la part du
gouvernement c'est donc aux états voire
aux comptes et que revient la décision
d'imposer ou non de nouvelles
restrictions il ya par exemple le comté
de los angeles qui impose de nouveaux le
port du masque en intérieur mais cette
décision fait polémique puisque certains
s'y opposent notamment des élus
républicains parce qu'ils estiment que
c'est en grande partie parce qu'il a la
possibilité de ne plus porter le masque
qu'il ya une forme d'incitation aux
américains à se faire vacciner il ya
aussi la question du masque à l'école
alors que la rentrée scolaire va
évidemment arriver à leurs doutes
prochain voire au mois de septembre
c'est hors de question pour le
gouverneur de floride ron de santis il
ne veut absolument pas que les élèves de
l'état de floride porte le masque en
classe il à imposer des lois à l'échelle
de l'état pour justement s'opposer à
toute imposition de l'obligation du port
du masque à l'école alors si le masque
fait débat aux états unis que dire du
vaccin c'est encore pire puisque des
états ont passé des lois pour empêcher
toute mise en place d'un passeport
vaccinale à des échelles locale que ce
soit dans des entreprises ou des
universités alors il ya quand même des
entités qui impose le vaccin c'est le
cas par exemple à new york où le maire a
annoncé que tout le personnel soignant
de la ville devra présenter une preuve
de vaccination ou à défaut un test pcr
chaque semaine il ya aussi donc des
entreprises et des universités qui avons
demandé à ce que leurs employés ou leurs
étudiants soient vaccinés évidemment
cela provoque énormément de débats même
des procédures judiciaires qui sont
intentés soit par des employés soit par
des étudiants qui s'opposent à cette
forme d'obligations alors sur ces
polémiques le gouvernement là encore ne
se prononce pas véritablement joe biden
ne souhaite pas à vouloir imposer
d'obligations et d'ailleurs la porte
parole de la maison blanche a été
interrogé à ce sujet il ya quelques
instants elle dit que ce n'est pas le
rôle du gouvernement fédéral d'imposer
une obligation de vaccination
il ya beaucoup avouent atom abonnés en
direct depuis washington
une cérémonie d'ouverture des jeux
olympiques de tokyo pas comme les autres
avec des gradins quasi
seulement quelques centaines à deux
personnes lésées pravo on le rappelle se
dérouleront à huis clos
beaucoup de nippons sont hostiles à
l'organisation de ces jeux en raison de
la crise sanitaire d'avoir aux abords du
stade olympique des manifestants qui
demandent l'annulation des jeux les
voici à ce jour des dizaines de cas
positifs ou vides ont été détectés au
sein du village olympique on voit cela
avec amaya souri à tokyo c'est le jour
tant attendu pour de nombreux athlètes
l'ouverture officielle des jeux
olympiques en événements qui divise et
ne fait pas l'unanimité dans l'archipel
depuis plusieurs semaines les
manifestations sont monnaie courante
pour demander l'annulation des jeux face
à une situation sanitaire qui se dégrade
un peu plus chaque jour
le japon est dans cette terrible
situation liée aux comics 19
par conséquent si des athlètes étrangers
viennent au japon ils peuvent être
infectés devenir un cas grave voir
mourir donc je ne pense pas qu'ils
devaient venir ni la hausse des cas de
co vite dans le pays provoque
l'inquiétude et le mécontentement du
corps médical mais aussi d'une partie de
la population
mais cette réticence s'est également
étendu à certaines délégations qui ont
hésité à envoyer leurs athlètes dans un
contexte sanitaire délicat de nombreux
sportifs testés positifs sont contraints
de dire au revoir au rêve olympique
ce mercredi après avoir annoncé ne pas
participer aux jo
la guinée est finalement revenu sur sa
décision
donc les vilaines pour comprendre que la
guinée ne sent pas de là bas
c'est cela que le chef de l'état a
compris il a pris son téléphone
il a contacté ses relations pour on
s'est rassuré que la délégation
guinéenne c'est là le mans protéger si
la pandémie a misé à mal l'organisation
des jo de la reconstruction
la cérémonie d'ouverture est également
entachée par le limogeage de son
directeur artistique pour des propos
jugés inappropriés sur le low cost il y
a plusieurs années en quelques mois
plusieurs membres de l'organisation des
jeux olympiques ont été démis de leurs
fonctions
de quoi ternir un peu plus cet événement
sportif emmanuel macron et au japon a
justement le président français qui a
assisté à la cérémonie d'ouverture et
puis demain direction papeete premier
déplacement du chef de l'état en
polynésie française une visite de trois
jours initialement prévus en avril 2020
mais différée en raison de la pandémie
alors quels sont les enjeux de cette
visite et des attentes des polynésiens
éléments de réponse avec estelle phare
le dossier est sensible et les attentes
des polynésiens nombreuses
la question des essais nucléaires
français devrait être au menu du premier
voyage d'emmanuel macron en polynésie
française en tant que chef d'état les
polynésiens attendent des annonces
concrètes notamment pour les victimes
des 193 essais nucléaires réalisés dans
l'archipel pendant 30 ans début juillet
à l'occasion d'une table ronde sur le
sujet à l'initiative du président
français
paris s'est engagé à assumer les
conséquences de ces essais nucléaires un
premier pas vers le dialogue qui
emmanuel macron entend poursuivre lors
de sa visite le président de la
république aura à coeur lors de ce
déplacement de promouvoir ce dialogue
étroit et transparent en encourageant la
mise en place rapide et concrète de
plusieurs actions tant sur la question
de la mémoire avec l'ouverture des
archives que sur les questions
d'indemnisation individuelle
autre enjeu de cette visite le
changement climatique et la
vulnérabilité de l'archipel face
notamment à la montée des eaux et aux
cyclones
emmanuel macron se rendra sur l'atoll de
manille où il visite
une centrale électrique hybride à noter
aussi qu'il se déplacera aux îles
marquises dans le but d'appuyer la
candidature de l'archipel au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
durant ce voyage il sera aussi question
d'évoquer l'importance stratégique de
l'archipel véritable porte sur le sud
pacifique pour l'hexagone
enfin jean l'armée de l'air française a
démontré sa capacité à déployer ses
avions en moins de 48 heures à 17 milles
kilomètres de la métropole
cet appareil dont trois avions de chasse
rafale de ravitailleurs et deux
appareils de transport sont arrivés à
tahiti objectif montrer que la france et
je suis un acteur fiable et qu'elle est
en capacité de venir en aide à ses
concitoyens si besoin
monsieur bacrot aura l'occasion
d'évoquer la stratégie rdo pacifique et
le positionnement que souhaite tenir la
france dans cet espace qui se polarise
enfin emmanuel macron aura selon
l'elysée un regard sur les deux autres
territoires français du pacifique
la nouvelle calédonie et wallis et
futuna visiter ces deux archipels
actuellement débarrasser du coc vide
aurait impliqué une quarantaine
incompatible avec une tournée
présidentielle précise l'elysée mais une
délégation d autorité de wallis et
futuna rencontrera emmanuel macron mardi
27 juillet sur le territoire polynésien
avant cela emmanuel macron va débuter sa
visite de l'archipel ce samedi sous le
signe de la lutte contre le coc vide par
une rencontre avec les soignants du
centre hospitalier de polynésie
française alors qu'une manifestation
contre le pass sanitaire est prévu dans
le même temps à papeete
et on en vient à faire un pegasys on
sait que les relations entre l'algérie
et le maroc ne sont pas au beau fixe
selon des médias rabat aurait espionné
des personnalités et citoyens algériens
lg se dit je cite profondément préoccupé
de quoi exacerber un peu plus les
tensions entre les deux voisins
maghrébins angoisses avec médias ce
qu'affi une indignation générale en
algérie provoquée par un logiciel qui
plus que jamais divise au coeur des
tensions
le programme israélien pegasus auquel
rabat aurait eu recours pour espionner
des citoyens et des personnalités
algériennes
des révélations qui ont provoqué
l'inquiétude d'alger alors que les
relations entre les deux pays voisins
restent houleuses l'algérie exprime sa
profonde préoccupation suite aux
révélations faisant état de
l'utilisation à large échelle par les
autorités de certains pays et tout
particulièrement par le royaume du maroc
d'un logiciel d'espionnage dénommé
pegasus contre des responsables et
citoyens algériens
en réaction le parquet général d'alger a
décidé d'ouvrir une enquête préliminaire
par crainte de voir sa défense nationale
menacée mais le maroc continue
d'infirmer les accusations et compte
poursuivre l' affaire devant le tribunal
correctionnel de paris
le royaume attaque en diffamation
amnesty forbidden stories à l'origine
des révélations sur pegasus c'est
organisme ont obtenu une liste contenant
pas moins de cinquante mille numéros de
téléphone qui aurait été mis sous
surveillance depuis 2016 dont 180
journalistes
des centaines d'hommes politiques et 65
chefs d'entreprise le maroc monte au
créneau
l'état marocain entend immédiatement
saisir la justice française car il
souhaite que toute la lumière soit faite
sur les allégations mensongères de ces
deux organisations qui avance des
éléments sans la moindre preuve concrète
et démontrer il s'agit d'un procès
d'intention médiatique infondées
visiblement créé de toutes pièces pour
déstabiliser la relation diplomatique
profonde entre le maroc et la france
si le maroc mise sur la justice pour
obtenir gain de cause
alger compte sur le soutien de la com
côté international et met en avant la
sécurité de la région étant directement
concernés par ces attaques
l'algérie se réserve le droit de mettre
en oeuvre une stratégie de riposte et se
tient prêt à participer à tout effort
international destiné à établir
collectivement les faits et à faire la
lumière sur la matérialité et l'ampleur
de ses crimes qui menace la paix et la
sécurité internationales ainsi que la
sécurité humaine
une affaire qui intervient alors que les
relations entre les deux territoires est
tendue principal sujet de discorde la
situation au sahara occidental
un conflit territorial qui oppose rabat
aux indépendantistes sahraouis soutenu
par alger le maroc revendique ce
territoire désertique
tout comme les indépendantistes du front
polisario
une situation qui s'envenime avec la
sphère pegasus les autorités algériennes
estimant que l'espionnage de rabat
intervient à des fins de surveillance de
ces indépendantistes est le pouvoir
cubain dans le viseur des états unis
washington qui impose des sanctions
financières au ministre cubain de la
défense en réponse je cite à la
répression de récentes manifestations
des sanctions pour leur symbolique mais
qui peuvent aboutir sur d'autres plus
punitive à joe biden l'a confirmé et ce
n'est qu'un début écoutez à ce propos le
porte parole du département d'état
américain
nous avons désigné aujourd'hui par le
biais du régime de sanctions globales
magnitski un individu est une entité
nos actions ne se limiteront pas à cela
nous allons continuer à examiner ce que
nous pouvons faire de plus non seulement
pour soutenir le peuple cubain mais
aussi et c'est important pour demander
des comptes à ceux qui sont si un
prudents dans leurs efforts et leurs
tentatives pour violer les droits de
l'homme du peuple cubain et tai chi minh
rights of
un retour en france le parlement a
adopté la loi contre le séparatisme
texte porté par gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'intérieur il prévoit des
mesures sur la neutralité religieuse du
service public
la lutte contre la haine en ligne ou
encore l'encadrement de l'instruction en
famille il s'agit d'une loi aussi bien à
gauche et à droite on conteste à
d'ailleurs leurs représentants ont
l'intention de saisir le conseil
constitutionnel on regarde ses tweets
avec celui d'abord du leader de la
france insoumis jean luc mélenchon du
nom à l'autre la loi contre les
musulmans adopté par 49 voix contre 19
jusqu'au bout des sept mois de débats
les insoumis ont tenu bon
les insoumis auront marqué et marqueront
encore leur opposition absolue à cette
loi contre républicaine dont la vocation
anti musulmane est assez claire pour
qu'elles aient été rappelés à cette
tribune avec les républicains je vote
contre le projet de loi comportant le
respect des principes de la république
et de lutte contre le séparatisme
si des mesures vont dans le bon sens il
passe à côté de l'essentiel pour lutter
efficacement contre la menace terroriste
islamiste lé préfet sont appelés à la
vigilance cet été face à la menace
terroriste une mise en garde lancée
aujourd'hui par gérald darmanin
en cause une vidéo adressée l'obtient
juillet à la france signé al qaïda le
groupe a terrorist dit je cite condamné
le blasphème incarné par les caricatures
de mahomet et selon le ministre de
l'intérieur lui lé président de la
république qui sont explicitement cité
un document publié alors qu'yves hier le
parlement a adopté la loi sur la
prévention des actes terroristes aient
choisi notamment de renforcer le
contrôle des condamnés pour terrorisme
sortant de prison et d'accroître le
recours aux algorithmes à
on en parle à tout de suite avec gilles
sacaze il est expert en en sûreté ancien
agent de la dgse fin bonsoir à vous
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france d'abord à propos de cette vidéo
d'al-qaïda dix ans dans laquelle la
france est vilipendé on sait que l'
usage de la propagande est une monnaie
courante chez cette organisation est ce
qu'il faut craindre un passage à l'acte
oui il faut que syndrome passage à
l'acte dans la mesure où le canal et
vérifiés pour le coup là c'est quelque
chose de sérieux on est aujourd'hui aux
capacités ont assez de recul pour
aujourd'hui être en capacité de mesurer
je dirais la la dangerosité la véracité
la solidité du message et c'est son
origine donc là il ya deux n'y a pas de
doute c'est un message qui émane de l'or
de l'organe habituel de communication
d'al qaïda et oui il faut prendre au
sérieux d'autant que assez souvent par
le passé et encore aujourd'hui on a le
temps de recul maintenant donc on peut
plus être surpris
chaque fois qu'il ya eu ce genre
d'annoncé assez suivie de sacy suivi d'
attaque alors date acte certes low cost
et et de basse intensité mais intacte
tout de même est-ce qu'on est justement
bien préparer vos croyez pour faire face
et déjouer ces attentats on n'est jamais
suffisamment préparé mon jeu je dis
toujours toujours la même chose s'il
voulait sur le moi j'ai jamais eu de
doute sur notre capacité à emporter
emporté la bataille je dirais
sécuritaire parce que la france est un
grand pays qui qu'à l'habitude de
situations games - au travers de son
histoire je veux dire de quoi on est
capable votre appareil sécuritaire
police gendarmerie armée services de
renseignement etc est parfaitement en
capacité de dire face là notre fragilité
je dirais aujourd'hui elle est plutôt
intellectuelle elle est plutôt culturels
c'est à dire que ça fait maintenant
quelques décennies et scellier
ou n'est plus qu'a affirmé avec fermeté
nos valeurs de les enseigner de la
laïcité par exemple qui était présenté
dans votre dans votre sujet c'est à la
fois une solution parce que ça fixe un
cadre je dirais d'ouverture sur pour les
religions de tolérante à vis des
religions mais c'est aussi une partie du
problème parce que ça je dirais que ça
fait table rase ça fait ça fait la place
si vous voulez il ya une demande de
spiritualité des gens n'en déplaise au
laïka et toute la déconstruction qu'on a
pu faire de notre offre je dirais
chrétienne catholique juive et c'est
donc endogène et qu'on a maté parce
qu'on a eu les mêmes problèmes à une
certaine époque mais qu'on a maté que la
république a réussi à mater office de
son histoire
à force de la déconstruire cette offre
aujourd'hui il ya les gens en recherche
un peu en mal d'identité en souffrance
vent je dirais à l'offre qui leur paraît
la plus dense et la plus sexy
aujourd'hui c'est l'islamisme
donc en réalité il n'ya rien de très
révolutionnaire le touche justement
gilles sacaze mais je vous posais la
question de savoir s'il était bien
préparés parce qu on est en pleine
affaire polémique à faire
pegasus cette affaire présumée de
dérapage de l'espionnage en cliquant
même destinée on le rappelle à lutter
contre le terrorisme est finalement
devenu selon des journalistes un outil
de renseignement sur des personnalités
notamment là dessus oui on voit
aujourd'hui c'est ce cadre est
véritablement changer si vous laissez
des techniques qui étaient jusqu'à
présent réservées
enfin je sais passionnés véritablement
dans le même sujet la médiathèque qui
était véritablement réservé à des états
ou à des réseaux mafieux un peu
structuré aujourd'hui il ya un accès
beaucoup plus facile bon marché en fait
à des outils hors-la-loi bien sûr mais
quand même à des outils
que tout le monde doit atteindre y
compris des organisations de moindre
et puis surtout la france étant affaibli
l'europe étant un peu le ventre mou
aujourd'hui de l'occident on a vu
émerger et déjà depuis depuis longtemps
si vous voulez des des puissances
intermédiaires qui n'ont absolument plus
peur de bousculer la france on a vu avec
le maghreb on a vu surtout avec les
turcs avant le maghreb
voilà aujourd'hui tous ces pays là
faisant des opérations sur notre sol il
se serait certainement pas permis parce
qu'il aurait eu peur des représailles
il se serait certainement pas permis la
même chose il ya quelques décennies quoi
donc incontestablement on est venu on
peut peut-être un peu de mou un peu
enfermé dans des des dogmes qui nous
empêche un peu d'agir et on fait plus
peur alors justement hier ya le
parlement a adopté la loi sur la
prévention des actes terroristes
est ce que cette loi elle vous semble
efficace
alors malheureusement je vais par be à
l'opposé de ce qui vient d'être dit
présenté côté la france a soumises qui
s'entend sans vergogne si vous voulez
fait passer l'état français pour un état
quasi raciste disant qu'on stigmatise on
stigmatise les musulmans etc
mais il continue à nier la dimension
idéologique si vous voulez ce terrorisme
il a le terroriser ses amendes
opératoire ce terrorisme il a une
motivation
il a un projet politique le terrorisme a
toujours un projet politique il n'ya pas
de terrorisme en sommes là aujourd'hui
on parle de terrorisme islamiste donc là
il ya forcément un lien avec l'islamisme
la seule motivation islamiste
donc c'est un projet politique qui
voulaient et nier cette évidence est
enfermé l'état le contraindre le
paralyser à ne pas de donner des mots à
ne pas nommer
le problème si vous voulez si c'est une
entrave aux nôtres c'est quoi c'est à
dire au sein du parlement dans
l'exercice de la démocratie donc ça
c'est un problème
ensuite je voulais je voulais dit aussi
moi je pense que la laïcité c'est une
part de la solution clairement parce que
ça fait ça fixer un cadre pour tout le
monde et ça tend la main j'irai parce
qu'il part ii de tolérance aussi dans la
légalité en tout cas dans la laïcité
mais c'est aussi une part du problème
parce que on ne voit on a plus d'offres
si vous voulez endogène en matière de
spiritualité merci beaucoup à vous
gilles sacaze expert en en sûreté et à
jean ancien agent de la dgse merci à
vous merci
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver dans 30
minutes pour une nouvelle édition rester
avec nous sur la défense
[Musique]
le maniement de la rumeur est vieux
comme le monde mais il est vrai que
l'arrivée des réseaux sociaux il va
donner une crédibilité destructrices
dans sa virtualité l'influencent a pris
toute sa place au coeur des
affrontements politiques et économiques
internationaux car elle est une
manifestation de la puissance capable de
peser sur l'évolution des situations
tous les jours nous entendons des
accusations de complotisme contre ceux
qui n'adhèrent pas à la pensée qu'on
dans le fond la théorie du complot
l'explication la plus simple et la plus
facile d'autant qu'elle permet de
désigner un bouc émissaire
évidemment coupable du pire vouloir
forcer le destin en récrivant une
histoire biaisée pour servir ses
intérêts ne tient pas dans la durée car
la vérité finit toujours par éclater
[Musique]